hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the four different kinds of
influenza that's type a
type b type c and type d so we're going
to start with type a
this is the one that you hear about the
most this is the one that
causes the seasonal epidemics that we
associate with influenza
so type a is classified into subtypes
you've heard of them i'm sure h1n1 h3n2
what do these letters mean well they're
actually based on
something called hemagglutinin
there we go hemagglutinin or ha and
something else
called neuraminidase
so hemagglutinin h a neuraminidase n a
what are these these are surface
proteins
and so when we're talking about h1n1 or
h3n2
these are both currently circulating
strains we're talking about strains that
have
slightly different hemoglobin so this
one has the h1 this one has the h3
or slightly different neurominigases
that's the n1 or the n2
and there's many different types so so
not just one two and three but
you've got many different types of
hemoglobin and many different types of
neuraminidase
and they can combine in different ways
and so this is how we classify
these based on their surface proteins
now what do these surface proteins do
you might be wondering hemoglutinin
binds to cyalic acid
which is something that's on the surface
of like target cells
so that it can enter those cells when it
binds to the cyalic acid when the
hemoglutinin
on the flu virion binds to the cyalic
acid on the target cell
that stimulates endocytosis the target
cell brings the flu virus in
and then it can begin its replication
cycle in there
neuraminidase is another surface protein
that happens at the end of that
replication cycle
when the offspring viruses
are budding off of the cell they have to
cleave that cyalic acid residue so cut
it and the neuraminidase does that so
these are important surface proteins
that
allow the flu to get into a cell and
then get out of a cell to go back the
only one excuse me
so back to type a type a is the only
type that is known
to have caused pandemics i'm going to
put this one in
all caps pandemics
so we know that epidemics are when you
have a lot of people getting sick
in a short period of time in a distinct
location
a pandemic is when an epidemic has taken
on global
worldwide proportions so impacting a
huge
amount of the world and so type a is the
one that is known to cause those major
flu pandemics it's also got the fastest
mutation
rate of all the types
i should say that all of the different
types of flu mutate all viruses mutate
but this one is the fastest one which is
in part
why it can cause these pandemics it also
another reason it can cause these
pandemics is because it has a broader
host range
so what does this mean this means there
are more species
that a type a influenza can infect and
i've listed just some of them here
ducks chickens pigs these are the ones
we maybe hear about the most when we
think of like
avian flu or swine flu jumping into
humans
but also horses dogs cats whales seals
gulls swans
and and more so lots of different
species
can be infected by type a
and i also want to mention that with
all of these different flu viruses you
see something called recombination
this is because they have a segmented
genome all that means is that their
genome is in different
pieces and so if you have two different
flu viruses let's say one from you know
ducks and one from pigs
and they jump into a human at the same
time and if those two flu viruses
jump into the same human cell at the
same time
you can get offspring viruses that
contain genetic material
from those two different flu strains
um this is called genetic recombination
it's also referred to as antigenic shift
which is a little bit different from
kind of your normal standard
mutation and that is what allows
uh type a to cause pandemics and to be
so
deadly now there are two different types
that we're talking today
talking about today that are used in
vaccines type a
is one of them now let's talk about type
b type b still certainly has the
hemagglutinin and the neuraminidase but
it's classified
differently type b has
diverged from type a just through the
process of evolution so it's a
different but related strain of a virus
and it's classified based on a place of
origin
so the different blue b
lineages are named on g for geographic
areas so with yamagata or victoria these
are ones that are circulating in the
population now
and and so they're named after the place
where they were
first detected or where they originated
and so this one does have a more
limited host range
fun fact type b flu can still infect
some other you know other species for
example it's been detected in
seals but it doesn't have this it
doesn't have this
big broad host range particularly with
animals
that are often in contact with humans
for agricultural practices like the
ducks and the chickens and the pigs
and so it doesn't have the very broad
host range it's much more limited
and this is probably why there are no
known pandemics so
that's not to say that it couldn't cause
a pandemic but it hasn't
historically since we've been able to
keep these records however it can still
cause death
and it does tend to be a little bit more
dangerous
for young people so sometimes when you
have um
young people get very sick or die from
the flu it tends to more often be this
type
b string and the type b strain
we know that um it you know even though
doesn't cause
pandemics it can still cause epidemics
it still tends to be seasonal
so that's something with type a and type
b they
tend to there are lots of cases in the
in the fall and winter and fewer cases
in the spring and summer so they have
that
seasonal kind of pattern
and this is the other one that is also
included
in our vaccine so when you get the flu
shot you've typically got
um you know two or three
of some of these so we've got a couple
of type a and a couple of type b
or maybe just two type a and one strain
of type b depending on
you know what year it is and what's in
that vaccine but um
there's there's generally going to be an
a strains and a b strain
represented now we'll move on to the
third type of flu that's type c this one
um still causes respiratory issues uh
but it's much milder
much milder symptoms certainly it still
mutates
but it's not one that we vaccinate
against so it's not present in these
vaccines over here
um it tends to be you know mild symptoms
and it's just really
not a public health concern
it's also not seasonal i'll go ahead and
write that on here as well
not seasonal
what i mean by that is that people can
get this one kind of
all year round um it doesn't have a huge
peak in the winter the way type a and
type b do
um and and so this one is just really
not that much of a public health concern
people get type c flu
and they think they have a cold it looks
like a cold and it doesn't typically
cause many problems beyond that
and then type d this one was discovered
more recently i think within
maybe about 10 years ago and it's not
known to infect humans at all
it is however found in cattle
and so with type d you might think well
we don't got to worry about that one and
that's
true maybe right now but certainly
um we know that flu type a is really
really good at it
can jump from from species to species to
species
and certainly there are other viruses
that
have started out in cattle
that eventually did jump into humans and
establish
a pattern of infecting humans and so
that's always possible as something to
be worried about in the future
so those are our um
type a type b type c and type d flu
i hope you enjoyed this video check out
some of my other videos like
introduction to viruses
that's something that you might also be
interested in or i have another video
on um disease pathogens jumping
from one species to another and so that
might be another one that you would like
to check out and thanks for watching
biology professor today